how would you like to be remember your
career how would you like the you know
the legacy and I would imagine you might
think of your mom when you think about
this but you know if she could that if
she could see you now how would you like
the the Kenny Rogers legacy I just like
people that I met to say I liked him he
never took advantage of me he gave me
everything he had and he asked nothing
in return
[ __ ] forever that's right look like the
remember well your musics been such a
huge gift for us over the years and I
know that dolly as somebody that is
obviously uh well is inextricable from
you yeah about you they think about her
and vice versa and she's gonna be there
and I can't I can't think I mean it's
only a few times in the last almost 30
years that you guys have played together
yeah they perform together on stage and
this will be this will be personal last
Wow how do you put it that I think it's
I think it's great and sad you know you
go out you enjoy the moment and when
it's over you say wow I'm glad I did
that
what does her friendship meant to you oh
it's been great thinking about dolly is
she has never unless you make her mad
and I've never done that
she always everything she says comes
from blood so you have to take it that
way she can say the most bizarre things
and she does and if you remember they
came from love you can't be upset